du grand au-delà, une vision m'a dit qu'un
grand guerrier et esprit Walker
m'aiderait dans ma quête homme qui a été de
l'autre côté et est revenu
j'aurais préféré quelqu'un d'autre mais
qui suis-je pour interroger le grand père d'
accord mais si nous  rouler ensemble nous
roulons pour la justice la justice est ce que je cherche
Kemosabe imaginez un continent entier
relié par un rail de fer
maintenant celui qui contrôle cela contrôle le
pouvoir futur qui fait passer l'empereur et les
rois pour des imbéciles je comprends que vous
avez un problème indien c'est drôle très
drôle rien n'est accompli sans
sacrifice il n'y a pas besoin d'être une guerre
arrêtez ce train
oh il n'y a pas moyen d'arrêter ce train je
pense que vous savez que les hommes bhoutanais
représentent la loi plutôt que ce soit maintenant
une fois que les étoiles de minerai de fer sont très difficiles à
arrêter
pour rire l'estomac je savais que ce serait
pire  pire comment cela pourrait-il être pire
c'est pire